[Musik]
diese woche hat mich schon sehr
beeindruckt wenn unter meinem fenster
demonstriert wird und es dazu
zusammenstößen von polizei und
demonstranten kommt was mir angst macht
ist die spaltung in dem land was mir
angst macht es dass sich zu manchen
menschen gar nicht mehr durchdringen die
demokratie wackelt nicht die demokratie
ist standhaft auch unser
parlamentarismus ich standhaft aber er
muss sich wehren es ist die woche in der
sich die afg unverhohlen verbündet mit
dem protest gegen die korona politik
af.de schleusen rechte medien aktivisten
sogar ins parlament wo sie abgeordnete
und minister verfolgen und verhöhnen
aufgeblasen wie könig davon distanziert
sich die fdp-spitze danach nicht aber
davon wie ihre parlamentarier draußen
stimmung machen gegen das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz mit
geschichtsrevisionismus wir haben wir
schon einmal 1933 und mehr brauche
erhält mehr 2020 die partei sucht
offensiv den schulterschluss mit den
querdenkern und der wilden mischung
ihrer anhänger was ergibt sich jetzt
anscheinend so weil er jährlich aus
völlig verschiedenen richtungen kommen
querdenken sind es eigentlich links
liberale bürgertum und die eigentlich
aus der grünen ecke fast um
ja und wir sind rechtskonservative und
jetzt hat sie sehen das richtig jetzt
sich das irgendwie von alleine zusammen
rechtskonservative neben der ard laufen
hier auch antisemiten reichs bürger und
verschwörungs erzähler mit
auch wenn zwei drittel auf diesen
demonstrationen nach immer normale
bürger sind der laute reste ruft
inzwischen verfassungsschützer auf den
plan
es geht nicht mehr nur darum dass
vielleicht ein paar spinner irgendwelche
populistischen radikalen forderungen
äußern sondern dass die brücken hier in
die vor allem bürgerliche mitte
funktionieren hier immer mehr anschluss
gefunden wird auch an die
extremistischen ideologien und insofern
müssen wir uns als verfassungsschutz
gedanken darum machen wie wir mit dieser
gesamtkonstruktion umgehen auf social
media-plattformen blühen gewaltfantasien
mit demos erreicht man da nichts mehr
gebäude stürmen regierung stürzen
diese verfluchten merkel schläger sollte
man aufhängen
die politik wirkt ratlos ich habe auch
ganz vielen der gegner diese kroner
politik gespräche angeboten und es gibt
einige die haben diese gespräche
abgelehnt weil sie es bringt gar nichts
mit euch zu reden also hin sagen leute
ich biete euch ein gesprächen und ihr
wollt das nicht es gibt leute die diesen
staat hassen ich glaube aber das ist die
kleine minderheit
ich glaube es gibt aber eine relevante
anzahl an menschen die sich ärgern mehr
aufmerksamkeit aber bekommen die lauten
eine sogenannte kunstaktion im
thüringischen altenburg die anlehnung an
nazi symbolik dabei unübersehbar den
bürgermeister wieder sowas an verhindern
könne er es nicht
es war eine angemeldete demonstration
und so wie sie abgelaufen ist das muss
man auf der anderen seite dazu sagen
sie hatten masken auf abstand gehalten
es wurde niemand angepöbelt im grunde
genommen war es ja eine mustergültig
durchgeführte demonstration im
westfälischen minden hängt die kogit
presse symbolisch von der brücke es
passt zu dem was journalisten heute auf
demos zu hören bekommen
[Musik]
auf querdenker bühnen ist es offenbar
mittlerweile schick sich
geschichtsvergessen mit ns
widerstandskämpfer zu vergleichen ich
bin voll kurzum elf jahre alt geworden
und ich wünschte ich hätte meinen
geburtstag normal verein plänen wir
mussten die ganze zeit leise sein weil
wir sonst vielleicht von unserem nachbar
verpetzt wort werden ich fühlte mich wie
bei anne frank im hinter rossi buchs
mäuschenstill sein mussten um nicht
erwischt zu werden
wir haben euch wenn jahn aus kassel und
ich fühle mich wie sie zu viel da ich
seit monaten hier aktive widerstand im
netz gefeiert wird übrigens nicht sie
sondern ein ordner der veranstaltungen
der noch während ihrer rede hin schmeißt
bei so einem schwachsinn mache er nicht
mit